it's great to be joined today by Nick
Lane who's professor of evolutionary
biochemistry at University College
London also the author of Five Books
some of which I've read including
Transformer the Deep chemistry of life
and death really appreciate you being on
today thank you well thank you for the
invitation pleasure to be here so I
think maybe to kind of frame the
conversation
certain areas of science are studied in
particular ways biology for example has
increasingly looked at genetic
information as one particular way that
we study it the origins of Life
intelligent life Consciousness whatever
this the approach to that study has been
a particular way over the last several
decades do you think generally speaking
that in these fields science is focusing
on the right questions and the right
approaches or is there sort of like a
paradigm shift that you think would be
more useful in answering some of the key
questions we don't yet have answers to
uh well I do think a paradigm shift
would be useful that's not to say
everything that people have been
studying is wrong
um you know it's it's taken us a long
way down the path but the the danger is
that if you think it's only about genes
and information and so on then you kind
of miss the broader Point there's more
to life than just genetic information uh
it's it's kind of a statement to the
obvious uh but but it's amazing how kind
of how much tunnel vision you can have
in research that people know effectively
where the funding is going to come from
the kind of things that will attract
funding the kind of things that you can
do a lot of science is about what you
can physically go and do in the lab what
uh what you know what technical
equipment do you have to go and explore
this question and then
I have to say science is intrinsically
quite conservative
um and any ideas that seem to be too far
outside the box uh tend to be squashed
uh you know and there's lots of ideas
outside the box and probably a fairly
High proportion of them probably
including some of my own uh ought to be
squashed but you you know you don't
squash them without thinking about it
you squash them after uh after you know
testing them trying it a little bit just
see where it takes you well that's very
interesting because there are some uh in
the you know science communication
Community I guess we would call it for
lack of a better term who often repeat
and like to say that one of the great
differences between science and religion
is that within organized religion
dissenting views are often squashed or
dismissed you become a pariah of sorts
in contrast to the scientific World
we're actually being able to debunk or
disprove previously uh uh held beliefs
is greatly revered and celebrated and
welcomed and there's great celebrity
available to scientists if they are able
to do that is that only true in some
sense or in some cases
um there is a lot of Truth in that which
is to say I won't speak for the for the
religious side of it but for the
scientific side yes I think most
scientists most of the time set out to
try and do something new to try and you
know over turn the apple cart to some
extent but the whole system of peer
review the whole system of of kind of
double checking everything and making
sure that uh that this is bona fide day
that this is solid research that you've
not missed something obvious that you've
you've got all the controls and all this
stuff well who does the peer review the
people who do the peer reviewer the
people who have in effect already
established their careers within
establishing the current Paradigm and so
as a group of people they are by Nature
I mean kind of almost by definition
relatively conservative and if you
really do come up with a completely new
paradigm then you really will overturn a
lot of people's work
um and so being revolutionary is not an
easy thing to do I'm not saying I'm
revolutionary I think I'm I'm just
talking plain common sense to be honest
with you but um but but this is this is
something that anybody who is genuinely
uh has transformative ideas in science
will come up against the
conservativeness of peer review and and
as I say probably nine out of 10 people
with what looked like mad ideas will
really have mad ideas that will turn out
not to be true and it's probably right
that they don't get too far but one out
of those ten maybe you know genuinely
brilliant or genius who who and and they
face uh kind of problems with the social
construction of science yes
to talk a little more specifically about
one of your books Transformer the Deep
chemistry of life and death as we kind
of mentioned at the start of the
conversation there's been a lot of focus
on genetic information in the field of
biology and
um one of the areas that you explore
again to the extent that I I hopefully
understood it somewhat correctly in the
book is about metabolism and looking at
sort of the cellular level and when we
talk about life and death really looking
at what is it that is happening there
now we've talked to scientists who
specialize in human longevity for
example and they've explained in a way
that is relevant to that particular
field the idea of over time the body
losing the ability to replace cells of
different types A deterioration of sorts
that that takes place Etc that's
specific to the field of longevity and
the the language sort of serves that
that purpose can you talk a little bit
about the the angle that you take here
and really this process that's at the
core or that you describe
yeah what I'm really interested in is is
how energy works in biology because it's
not it's not as you might imagine it
it's actually electrical I suppose a lot
of people might immediately think it's
electrical if you think about
Frankenstein's monster or something you
have an electric shock and off they go
um and we are all our side ourselves we
have these things called mitochondria
they're often called the power packs of
cells and they have they have an
electrical charge across their membrane
which is a you know a trivial charge
we're talking 150 200 millivolts but if
you were to shrink yourself down to the
size of a molecule
um and kind of stand next to the
membrane the membrane is so thin it's
it's five millionths of a millimeter in
thickness five nanometers thick
um that the the actual strength of the
field that you would experience if you
were there is about 30 million volts per
meter which is equivalent to a bolted
lightning so this is what's keeping us
alive and and nobody imagined uh until
you know it's a few decades this is not
new information but a few decades ago it
came as really quite a shock to discover
that effectively life is powered by
electrical charges and electrical Fields
across membranes and so for me the
interesting question is why how did that
get going it's quite a complex system
what happened at the origin of life this
is conserved across all of life and also
if we look across this you know whole
four billion year history of life on
Earth it's pretty weird as well what we
actually see is the first two billion
years is just bacteria and really
nothing else and actually if you think
about it from the point of view of
bacteria they're still there they're
still just bacteria or nothing so we
have a four billion year history of life
on Earth which is just bacteria and then
at one point
um which is to say all the evidence
suggests at one point you you have the
emergence what looks like quite an
Abrupt emergence in geological terms of
our own type of cell what are they
called eukaryotic cells or that means a
cell with a nucleus and the nucleus is
where we put our DNA in the the genes
um and and so we have the same cell type
that plants do and you know mushrooms
fungi and so on do and and large single
cell Critters things like amoeba they
also have the same cell structure now if
you think if you think about you know we
know all we've got all of these Gene
sequences
from the history of life from bacteria
all around the world and what it tells
us is that the bacteria in another group
that look a lot like them called archaea
have basically explored the kind of Gene
sequence space the all the possibilities
that you could have across all of
evolution from exploring different Gene
sequences they've done that much better
than our type of cell have them
eukaryotic cells have and yet somehow
they got stuck in this rut they they
remain simple in their morphology
they're not simple in their genetics or
they're biochemistry but they're simple
in their size and their shapes and you
know the the kind of things going on
inside and so
it seemed I would say that that says
they're not limited by genetics they're
not limited by the searching of sequence
space they're limited by something else
and that's something I think is the
structure because what all eukaryotes
have in common is they in they they
swallowed a bacterium one billion years
ago which went on to become these power
packs of mitochondria with this powerful
electrical charge across all the
membranes so effectively they
internalized respiration in a
compartment
which which allowed them to scale up
become large and complex and and more or
less get beyond the constraints that
energy has so obviously cells need
energy but not many people have thought
about well how is it provided and and
and what we actually have is we have
genes in our mitochondria and genes in
our nucleus and you need both sets of
genes to control this electrical charge
and that's that's the kind of a shift in
cell structure which changed the whole
history of evolution and everything
that's possible and if we look for life
on other planets and you think are we
going to find the same kind of thing
that we're going to find people are we
going to find intelligent aliens
whatever it may be the likelihood is
we'll find bacteria for exactly the same
reasons that the Earth was dominated by
bacteria for most of its history when we
think forward based on this framework
you know I recently read the book
precipice by Toby ORD which looks at
some of the more uh I guess we would say
anthropogenic risks to humanity and he
sort of goes through uh nuclear war
climate change Etc and kind of frames
the conversation in from what we know
here's roughly how long species last
here's roughly what we think about
mammalian species and and take sort of
that approach to how long might Homo
sapiens last if we were to not destroy
ourselves but it's a very socially uh
informed kind of perspective when you
think about the future of homo sapiens
is that side the one that seems most
predictive or is what we're talking
about here quite literally how cells get
their energy and the waste of cells
which do you think as Humanity continues
to presumably Advance technologically
will bear a greater weight on what
eventually happens to humans
well I mean I I fear for the next phase
of human history I mean we are very
capable of screwing this up badly
um and and effectively eliminating
ourselves from the planet now we will
not under any circumstances eliminate
life from the planet I suppose a
full-scale nuclear Armageddon might just
do it but even then there will be plenty
of bacteria left I'm sure digging down
in the crust and so on and probably
plenty of eukaryotes down there as well
so this transition from just the
bacteria to uh to to to eukaryotic cells
I don't think we'd have to go through
that again and we've had you know major
mass extinctions in the past where where
70 80 90 percent of of species get wiped
out
um you move the clock forward by five
ten million years and and you have a
fully vibrant planet again so really
what we're in danger of doing is
destroying ourselves and everything we
care about
um and uh and and then the planet will
readjust and in 10 million years it'll
just be without us
um would we get back all the Majesty
that we see around us it's hard to say
it depends just how effective we are in
wiping everything else out so that's my
biggest fear because there are tipping
points and there is it's it's all very
well to say we should be optimistic we
can fix any problem we put our minds to
I would agree with that but we need the
political will we need the political
governance and Mana you know we're also
capable of scuppering the best laid
plans that Humanity can come up with and
it may be we just leave it too late
beyond beyond some Tipping Point so
that's the biggest threat to humanity it
doesn't matter how long mammalian
species might normally last we can do
ourselves in within the next 20 years or
something we're in a special unique
situation now yeah we really are unique
in the sense that I don't think any
other species Beyond well not even a
virus could take out the entire planet
in the way that we're capable of doing
so I don't know that it's necessarily
helpful to think in general terms about
the future I think we need to fix very
specific problems now but if we're
thinking about you know if we do go into
those general terms and think about well
uh can we for example solve lifespan so
that we live indefinitely
um I think it will be difficult
what I mean there's two there's two
aspects in biology that says it's
possible one of them is that life itself
is effectively Immortal in the sense
that there is an unbroken chain of cells
that go right back to the origin of life
and those cells were metabolically
active all the way through
um so so there's no necessity that
damage accumulates and and overcomes
everything and then there are some you
know things like flatworms and so on
there's a few fairly simple animals that
uh are in effect Immortal and can live
indefinitely but they're usually pretty
simple
and the things that we most care about
are
you know our minds and our minds are
incredibly delicate structures made up
of sign happening or trillions of
synaptic connections
um and and
to preserve those is is a is a very
difficult thing to do and the the
decision Evolution has made historically
if you like is um
how much effort do I want to put into
the preservation of the organism
compared to the replication of the
organism and and the decision for humans
is well you know 70 80 90 years
um that allows you time to have a few
kids and and look after them and even
the grandparents can help look after
them whatever it may be this is a kind
of an evolutionary bargain if you like
and the bargain says you have a limited
lifespan because this is all we're going
to invest in your own prolongation as an
organism so we need to know the kind of
the details of the small print that says
here's why you here's why your life is
coming to an end and see if we can fix
that
um a lot of people wouldn't want to fix
that uh I think it would be quite
difficult in any case to do it
um so it's not it's not if you like a
threat in the immediate future I don't
think though you could talk to other
people who think that we already have
people on this planet who are going to
live to a thousand or something
short of that and I've interviewed some
of those people yeah Aubry de gray has
been saying for 20 years I think that
the first person to live to a thousand
has lived in the limited time we have
left it's almost cliche because it's so
repeated now and sometimes things get
repeated and do we do they really make
sense but there's this idea that
the best we can hope to do with standard
human bodies is about 120 or 125 years
and that's the maximum human lifespan
yeah and so so that generally makes
sense to you that until we really start
making modifications that make us not
quite human that's going to be a very
difficult upper limit to get to get
Beyond
I I think it will be very difficult yes
I'm not saying it's not possible
um but uh but but it will be it will be
difficult yes and I think it'll take us
a while longer yeah I don't think we
understand biology nearly well enough
yet to get beyond that limit personally
right we've been speaking with Nick Lane
professor of evolutionary biochemistry
at University College London will link
to a number of his books including
Transformer the Deep chemistry of life
and death I really appreciate your time
today
thank you it was a pleasure